pas un coup d'état mais un coup d'éclat
juan garrido le leader de l'opposition à
l'intérieur de la base aérienne
militaire de la carlotta à caracas dans
un message de trois minutes diffusée par
les médias sociaux il a lancé
l'opération liberté le début de la phase
finale qui doit selon lui conduire à
l'abandon du pouvoir par le président
nicolas sma d'euros et à des élections
libres et démocratiques
il était entouré d'une trentaine de
militaires armés qui ont fait défection
et qui lui ont servi de garde rapprochée
ses membres des forces armées de la
garde nationale porte des rubans bleus
signe de ralliement
aujourd'hui un important contingent des
forces armées à caracas et ailleurs au
pays nous a rejoint dit il
auprès de lui leopoldo lopez son
prédécesseur à la tête de l'opposition
qui a été libéré par d'autres militaires
alors que condamner par le régime maduro
il était en résidence surveillée il
appelle tous les vénézuéliens à sortir
en masse dans les rues pour manifester
demain 1er mai ceci est un appel en
finir avec usurpateurs par des
manifestations pacifiques par tous ou au
venezuela et dans le monde dit il
leopoldo lopez et son époux se sont
réfugiés à l'ambassade du chili
les affrontements avec des forces de
l'ordre se sont produits dans le
quartier altamira non loin de la base
militaire de la carlotta des blindés ont
lancé des bombes lacrymogènes
l'un d'entre eux a même foncé sur les
manifestants il ya eu des blessés à
caracas et dans d'autres villes du pays
plusieurs par balles pour le
gouvernement maduro il s'agit d'un coup
d'état manqué à l'instigation des états
unis le ministre de la défense le
général vladimir padrino a parlé de
tentative protestent par quelques
militaires berner par l'extrême droite
laïque tito jeune ali date et la
démocratie mais nasrallah et gaieté
mauvais et il affirme que la plus grande
partie de l'armée et loyale au président
maduro point coelho a reçu l'appui des
états unis et de leader du groupe de
lima dont fait partie le canada
le canada salue leur courage et nous
appelant le régime du maduro de se
retirer et à permettre la résolution
pacifique de cette crise qu la suite du
drame se jouera demain 1er mai dans les
rues du venezuela jean michel leprince
sera du canada à montréal